he is the grammy award-winning recording
artist
and the founder of a line of golf wear
called bogey boys he is mclemore how are
you macklemore
i'm doing great how you doing man i am
doing fine i've got so many questions
for you i've got so many so many
questions for you
uh starting with the the the name of
your uh
golf line shouldn't it be birdie boys
mclemore i mean if you want
you know i don't think not for my game
okay not for my game that happens every
couple weeks
at best uh you know we're just trying to
make bogey the new par man
you know car is just so challenging but
bogeys
it's kind of the new par i like it i
like it
you had me hello there because i can't
get off that bunky train man i'm i think
i'm perfect for your line of clothing
i am a bogey boy i am raising my hand
and saying that
for sure yes yes it is a very
challenging game and uh
you know sometimes the bogey just feels
like you
like you got a birdie man and um yeah
this is for the golfer that
wants to stand out a little bit want
something a little bit different than
what's in the pro shop
and uh maybe take some lagoon or two per
game well i'm looking right now
you know look the collection's got
everything from tees to socks and polos
and jackets and hats
sweaters stuff what about i'm looking at
uh this
very green uh out uh get up i think that
you've got
was this at the uh pebble beach i think
that's what this is what i'm looking at
right now
mclemore yeah it could have been
definitely worse than green and pebble
oh absolutely you're in a cart looks
like you're on a like one of those uh
motorcycle carts that you're working
here yeah they love to put me on that
scooter
they've done it twice in a row now
they're like hey man yep you're playing
and uh go get on the scooter and drive
down the 18 fairway
and uh we're going to get a bunch of
hate tweets for you disrespecting the
game of golf go ahead
but i'm looking you've got backup right
here and bill murray that's a great
photograph what are you talking about in
this picture right here with you and
bill
mclemore uh bill is probably
you know getting in my head giving me a
line
not there you know we were against each
other opposing teams but uh
okay you know he's he's a fantastic man
obviously a legend
and uh and a pretty damn good golfer i
told him his swing is very
buttery i don't know if he knew what
that meant but um
it was very clear to me just great tempo
that's what it means to me
buttery means that it's something that
doesn't have a lot of
jerky movement to it it's it's just uh
it's just
take it back and then just swing it
through and then follow through
and if you could just be buttery for two
damn seconds like me i just i need a
shot of like novocaine to the head i
think too much man
i think too you know i just don't need
to and i'm also
i'm one of those players that you know i
just don't i don't have the setup like
i don't like okay i got to go through
this i got to put the ball on like if
i'm teeing it up i put the ball on t
i put the t in the ground and then i
step back then i make sure this is there
and that's there i just don't do that i
just
i just get up and i hit it and then when
i hit it i'm like thinking what a
beautiful day it is and i'm not thinking
about my next shot i
i just i don't know if i got it you know
what i mean that's just me
yeah no i'm i'm overthinking for sure
there's no pre-shot routine
it's it changes all the time it's uh
yeah
it's a it's a game that i have not
figured out yet don't know if i ever
will
so what's your handicap right now back
tomorrow what do you got um i
i ended before you know the winter came
i ended it at 10
6 i want to say and um i feel like i'm
playing now more like at
13 or 14 but you know
yesterday was the first day that you
could enter scores again up here in the
northwest so
we'll get back on it i i'm i'm entering
some local tournaments so i would like
that handicap just a little bit higher
so when you're saying you're entering
local tournaments are you
are you trying to be like actually
competitive and start to
maybe turn your attention to that a
little bit
i just want to beat tony romo at some
point in my life
we all do i just don't i just don't know
if that's gonna happen i'm sorry to say
macklemore no it's definitely not that
guy can actually play golf
who is the best um musician
player period like who's the tony romo
of music
essentially is what i'm saying um so i
have not played with that person
because everyone that i play with is
around my skill level or worse
but um i hear
it's so random i mean i hear kenny g's
good okay
i hear um
who's the alice cooper yeah alice cooper
is like a four
handicap get out of here yeah he's
completely addicted to the games played
for a long time
okay and is really he's a stick
besides that i couldn't tell you who's
actually good um i mean i know justin
timberlake's pretty good
yes but i don't think he's as good as
alice cooper alice cooper is the goat
of musicians that play golf let's just
put it that way what did you what did
you
my uh my guy across the way here chris
brockman's looking this up as you're
mentioning names what do you got for me
over there chris yeah macklemore
kenny g's a stick he's a 1.6 are you
serious
okay never mind that was cooper
so kenny's close to giving strokes back
to the course is what you're saying
kenny's close basically saying no thanks
i'm i'm good i'm good i'll shoot par
today
wow damn hey you got something to shoot
for
macklemore no doubt about that bogey
boys is available exclusively on
bogeyboys.com
let's talk a little bit about um the
professional football team up there in
the
beautiful pacific northwest that you
root for mclemore what is going on
with russell wilson and your favorite
football team what's going on with that
i knew exactly when there was just like
a second pause i was like and now we're
going to transfer
into the anxiety prone topic
of russell wilson and the clc um yes
you know i i don't know i i feel like i
need to give russell a call at this
point
and um get a little intel because i
don't know what's going on
and um yeah it's a little nerve-wracking
man when it first happened i was like oh
russell
barking this isn't going to be a this
isn't going to be an issue he just wants
a little more protection now i'm like
does he
does he want to bounce um which would be
very sad man
you know we we we have a long-standing
love for russell up here um
he's a great dude good friend of mine i
just would
be very sad to see russell wilson leave
the hawks
no i do you have that i know you're
friends with him and you know you're
you you are part owners of the the
sounders together but do you have that
relationship with him where you could
call him up and say what's going on and
even potentially broker something
mentally for him that he could go to the
cr i'm serious
like do you have that sort of
relationship mclemore
you know i don't know i don't know if
i'm putting myself in the broker or
anything
category but um i do have i do have that
level of friendship that i could call
him up and and see where his head's at
um yeah i remember when he signed his
deal talking to him we were doing a bose
commercial and
and going over the deal that he was
trying to get in yeah he's
he's someone that um yeah we we have
that type of relationship
i don't know what that's going to change
right maybe i could work some of my
magic
and get him to stay in the northwest
well again
it just makes no sense though you know
obviously pete is going to be
70 years old he acts like he's seven and
he's
he's he's gonna be he's going to be well
he's like the dick clark of coaching
right i mean so
so he he he's going to be a 70 year old
head coach the oldest in the nfl which
is amazing that i'm actually saying
those words about pete carroll
but so why and why why would
it makes no sense to chase him out or
create a situation where russ isn't
comfortable but there is clearly
something that russ has an
an and issue with uh i'm wondering about
this
concept that i'm hearing a lot about
mclemore and that is
that he and sierra want to maybe go to
the east coast because it would help her
music career or his entrepreneurial
career
what do you think of that concept
i don't know i mean you know they got us
a place down down south
they have a plane i i get it
i get the convenience factor of what
that might do
i don't know if that's the driving force
behind this i think
literally he would like some more
protection i think that the conspiracy
theories around sierra driving this
thing
are probably false she is she's got a
very successful career herself
she's able to travel easily and and make
it work i just don't think that she's
the mastermind behind him leaving the
hawks yeah i just also don't
know if i believe that wouldn't that be
crazy
mclemore if uh eventually if it is true
uh that russell part of the reason why
he wanted out of seattle is because it's
not enough of a music town that doesn't
strike me as um
making much sense to me either no right
no no i think i mean obviously
you get on a plane and you're down in
l.a and in two hours
to 220 and particularly you know they're
flying a pj
it's quick it's not it's not a long
journey
um it's depressing up here i can't lie
you know there's times where i'm down in
los angeles and i'm like what am i doing
with
my life again why did i choose this you
know you can leave
but um it's magical up here definitely
rust feels the magic
and i think that they're going to work
it out i i honestly think that he's
going to be with the hawks next year
i'd rather put money on it i agree with
you i i
i just think that that sometimes you do
need to say stuff
publicly and personally i i think what
happened with brady is just messing with
a lot of
tremendous pro bowl if not future hall
of fame quarterbacks as heads
you know the fact that he went with knew
knew one way to do it for 20 years and
said screw it i'm just going to try it
one
other time with somebody else and right
and he beat everybody including aaron
rodgers
that you know rusty didn't have the
opportunity to take on the bucks in the
in the in the uh playoffs but i i just
think that
maybe you know the way somebody has done
something
i guess in the analogy you just
mentioned maybe brady is like the sun
the sunshine weather of los angeles that
makes you sit there and say maybe
i i don't need to stay where i am you
know what i mean
yeah completely i mean brady
is an anomaly he doesn't make sense
i don't know what he eats i know that
it's nothing that i eat
and he is he looks like he's 25 years
old
and he just keeps getting rings and for
the majority of my adult life i have
hated tom brady
um mostly hated on him and
obviously a big part of that is the
patriots win over the seahawks
super bowl when we didn't give it to
marshawn but um
this year i just
when he got the ring again and he was
weekend at bernie's partying throwing
the super bowl
trophy uh i was just like you know what
do i actually have a soft spot for tom
brady is this developing right now
because it feels something's shifting
inside of me i don't like it
but something's shifting it's it's i
finally become someone that can say
i don't hate tom brady and that's and
that's
maybe progress i'm not sure yeah because
like
when when he was stumbling out of the
party like he said weekend at bernie's
you know we've all been that guy we've
also been the guy who's let
helped a friend out too but we've all
been like this might be the most
relatable
brady has ever been even though the
numbers and the performance is
thoroughly unrelatable to any other
human being on the planet
you know yes completely completely i
finally was like you know what
i like that guy is it because he's no
longer
with belichick mclemore what do you
think
i think that that was a huge part of it
you know that kind of one-two
evil genius combo the slate gate
leading into you know i just always seem
to just kind of have like a little way
to finesse the league
and i i never like and they always won
i'm nev unless it's my team i don't i
don't i don't like to see one team just
continue to win
so uh before i let you go mclemore
bogeyboys.com
is where bogey boyz is is uh is is
specifically
acquired golf and lifestyle clothing
brand did you
have you been part of like the actual
design like hey i want to i want a
shirt to look like this i want the
script on the back of one of the shirts
to look like that
is that yeah i did everything i did
everything with um
with the designer name nick guzman down
in la we did it together
and um yeah i think that anything that
i'm gonna get into creatively
i want my fingerprints on it and this
was one of those projects that i started
and had no idea that it would take a
year and a half of my life
no kidding and that it would be 2021
until it came out
and i spent a lot of time a lot of money
and a lot of love and put it into it and
my wife was like what are you doing
where when are we gonna see any of this
cash back
go down in the basement and wrap make us
some cash
but um you know it it's it's been live
now for a week
and it's done really really well and
it's completely exceeded my expectations
i'm really excited about it i think the
clothes turned out
great and it's a labor of love and when
you put something
when you put love into something and
it's not about that financial return
it's just about
you know making something that you enjoy
and the product's usually good and
that's what's happened here
i'm excited about it well i mean do they
make it for kids my oldest loves wearing
colorful stuff
and um and he loves wearing it on a golf
course too
uh i i think he's perfect
keeps saying you know she's she's in
design sessions with me so we're gonna
have to get some kid stuff going so
that would be great i mean uh you know i
it because it does it looks different
it really looks different and it's
definitely a choice you know what i mean
and i think it's just like you know what
i shoot bogey and i don't care who the
hell knows it i'm gonna have a good time
out here
and i'm gonna try and if i'm par or i'm
birdie that's great but you know i back
on the bogey train who cares i look good
did i did i nail that exactly did i nail
it that's exactly it
no i'm gonna definitely steal all that
[Laughter]
what's mine is yours
what's mine is yours uh and uh i'm a
size
uh large okay very good bogeyboys.com
is where uh this fantastic new golf and
lifestyle clothing brand can be acquired
uh it would take me forever to grow that
mustache so i'll just leave that to you
and that'll be that i appreciate the
time
thank you so much brother appreciate it
let's do this more often i've really
enjoyed the chat i'd love to keep
talking sports with you for sure
the very least absolutely thanks for
having me you got it mclemore
on twitter and instagram same at bogey
boys
on instagram that's mclemore the grammy
award-winning
artist and founder of bogey boys right
here on the rich either show my wife
says the same thing go into the basement
and rap
yeah and make some money make some money
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here